una nueva noche de toque de queda en
esta localidad del estado de wisconsin
ahora mismo las calles están tranquilas
en que nos llevamos varios días sin
incidentes
eso sí en unas horas tenemos visita del
presidente de donald trump que quiere
hacer política con la cuestión de la
inseguridad la violencia y la policía en
sí sí bien llevamos días en los que aquí
se corea el nombre de jake blake víctima
de unos disparos por la espalda por un
agente de la policía local donald trump
se va a reunir precisamente con
representantes de la ley el orden unas
palabras que ha estado coreando en los
últimos días que nos recuerdan a
campañas como la del presidente nixon
también conservador y que ahora mismo es
la gran baza del republicano que quiere
hacer frente a los 'números y en las
encuestas que no le son favorables la
gestión de el coronavirus le está
pasando factura a donald trump y joe
biden ha intentado con sus palabras en
el día de ayer en pittsburgh pues
demostrar que él no es el candidato
contra la ley el orden vamos a ver cómo
le va a pasar factura a uno y a otro en
esta contienda de noviembre de momento
que no se sigue siendo foco de la
actualidad visita de donald trump y aquí
está
en las calles